politics is a brutal business riven with
rivalries and shifting loyalties and
simmering ambitions and when the top job
is up for grabs the heat really is on
it looks like it's shaping up to be a
very a very kind of nasty leadership
campaign if that does happen of course
whoever wins will be providing over a
very fractured party at a point at which
we're going to a once-in-a-lifetime cost
of living crisis the uk's next prime
minister isn't chosen by the general
public instead just conservative mps
over there in parliament will whittle
the list down most likely to just two
remaining candidates and then the
conservative party membership in the
country around 160 000 of them will cast
their postal ballots
a 2019 analysis found that 70 percent of
the members are male 56
are older than 55 and a third of them
live in london and the southeast of
england expect policies which appeal
explicitly or implicitly to that
demographic
the conservative party models itself as
the party for business conservative
voters generally don't support high
taxes they inhibit enterprise and growth
they believe so it's no surprise that at
this early stage of the contest the
leadership rivals are falling over
themselves to promise tax cuts look i
believe in a lower tax
lower regulation cut the red tape
economy i think no conservatives should
raise taxes either
what you need are smart tax cuts that
will grow the economy i've always been a
low tax conservative i'm delighted that
others are following whatever you decide
on economic policy has risk whichever
way you go but there i think the much
greater risk is not having the tax cuts
but if you're cutting taxes how will you
fund public services nearly 6.5 million
patients are currently waiting for
hospital treatment in england such as
knee replacements or eye surgery and the
next pm needs to have a plan
low wage growth big increases in energy
bills and price inflation nudging into
double figures have all created a cost
of living crisis here in the uk
something the new prime minister is
going to have to tackle
first and foremost people are suffering
the most this country of course of those
who are vulnerable 2.6 million kids
going hungry you just send more cash to
them directly on the other side you also
need to have a serious program for how
we're going to fix this country and fix
our problems
remember this is an election in which
only conservatives can vote the other 47
million people of voting age can only
watch and wait and hope for the best
paul brennan al jazeera london